Caption: everyone I'd like to introduce Wes
Caption: Wilson talking about how to use machine
Caption: learning to make life better people say
Caption: I have it's Wes thank you very much for
Caption: welcome I like to thank everyone knew
Caption: all the volunteers and organizers of the
Caption: hearth putting on some amazing events
Caption: and I thank all you guys for voting for
Caption: my talk hopefully you find it
Caption: interesting I wasn't sure if Frank
Caption: Andrews were got everyone as excited as
Caption: we get invited so here we go
Caption: of course thank you to all the sponsors
Caption: who films with that go I was speak here
Caption: for clarity so about 12 years ago a 12
Caption: year old boy came into a clinic Markham
Caption: Ontario Canada is my hometown picture
Caption: dear small towns little hockey town I
Caption: taught you drilling and he came into the
Caption: clinic that he had a 10 out of 10
Caption: headache the worst headache even that he
Caption: was vomiting
Caption: they had no nausea at all physicians are
Caption: trained to treat this as a brain bleed
Caption: until proven otherwise
Caption: that's very serious we can see the image
Caption: in his brain but there's no bleed
Caption: instead was a brain tumor the size of a
Caption: golf ball in his fourth ventricle his
Caption: brain secreting cerebral spinal fluid
Caption: which is causing an increased
Caption: intracranial pressure causing a medical
Caption: emergency he sent down to the closest
Caption: city to Toronto at the hospital sick
Caption: shoulder where emergency surgeries done
Caption: in order to save his life hospital sick
Caption: children where I first started and got
Caption: into pediatric neural oncology brain
Caption: tumors and choli on the number one cause
Caption: of cancer-related death and children
Caption: worldwide and this fact is staggering
Caption: once you realize that it is a rare task
Caption: childhood leukemia make up the vast
Caption: majority of all cancers the not even
Caption: close the amount of deaths from brain
Caption: dude there's lots of kinds of brain
Caption: tumor these are a homogeneous set of
Caption: diseases many subjects and they all have
Caption: they're all various degrees of
Caption: aggressiveness they respond differently
Caption: to different treatments so it could be
Caption: surgically affected some can't for
Caption: example the type of medulloblastoma
Caption: known as a wint paper glass dome ax has
Caption: a malfunction in one of its pathways and
Caption: this causes a side effect that the
Caption: blood-brain barrier gets disrupted now
Caption: this is actually advantageous for
Caption: children with the wint type video about
Caption: stoma and what this means is that the
Caption: compromised blood brain barrier actually
Caption: allows more chemotherapy agents to cross
Caption: the blood-brain barrier and get the
Caption: tuner which is why wint tumors have a
Caption: better prognosis than children in the
Caption: state group 3 which is of the same
Caption: possum module up though with different
Caption: types of treatments very different
Caption: tumors subtypes are important to keep
Caption: they don't develop so how do we tell the
Caption: difference between these types of tumor
Caption: well for some cancer let's say you had
Caption: skin cancer melanoma or breast cancer it
Caption: can be very obvious you can look out
Caption: under a microscope they'll have
Caption: different morphologies they look very
Caption: different but for brain tumors this can
Caption: be problematic medulloblastomas under
Caption: the microscope but identical upon us
Caption: fellow you can't tell it it
Caption: traditionally the way these tumors have
Caption: been distinguished it's been where are
Caption: they in the brain so if you had a tumor
Caption: growing on the pineal gland with a
Caption: picture here I don't what they want to
Caption: have perfect neuroanatomy mind but great
Caption: everything was the same then they say oh
Caption: it's on the pineal gland it's up on
Caption: elastomer
Caption: but this can be a problematic way to
Caption: diagnose frankly for example this image
Caption: here taken from the UCLA neurosurgery
Caption: page from the pine box don't age there's
Caption: a great resource of information to
Caption: patients but there's a little subtypes
Caption: under this image that says after they
Caption: were second the tumor and analyzed it it
Caption: ended up actually being as well last
Caption: moment it wasn't funny above the little
Caption: so how do we diagnose the subject how do
Caption: we figure out which treatments are gonna
Caption: work well there's two groups in the
Caption: world that kind of do it the best with
Caption: one in New York New York and one in
Caption: Heidelberg Germany now most people use
Caption: Germany it is the gold
Caption: the one that everyone they do it the
Caption: best they have the most robust algorithm
Caption: it's a secret but it's considered the
Caption: best so a patient comes in to Perth
Caption: Perth Children's Hospital with a brain
Caption: tumor cut on a bio freeze it send it to
Caption: Heidelberg Holabird then runs some tests
Caption: on it they use what's called a DNA
Caption: methylation array DNA methylation you
Caption: might have heard about it those
Caption: epigenetics is a big buzzword these days
Caption: trading genes on and off but it can also
Caption: act with just a fingerprint a
Caption: fingerprint in your genome which can be
Caption: associating different paper to and they
Caption: have a black box other than that and
Caption: look at this profile tell you what it is
Caption: so once they finish analyzing it they're
Caption: right at the report they look at the
Caption: histology is welding a little slice they
Caption: send that back to Perth where we were
Caption: like ah ok this is what big fat now this
Caption: can be problematic because that can take
Caption: time and sometimes you have to start
Caption: treatment but for a couple weeks pops
Caption: when you get a diagnosis and if you have
Caption: to start treatment before you know what
Caption: the tumor is why even bother diagnosing
Caption: it it's not going to affect your
Caption: treatment plan it doesn't change it now
Caption: for other nations or maybe our poster to
Caption: Germany there are other problems that
Caption: this presents as well one is cost not
Caption: every country can afford this ship
Caption: samples to Germany back now parts
Caption: Children's Hospital to see you guys know
Caption: does have a special deal with Idol birth
Caption: we get it stripped our sample free in
Caption: exchange they get to keep the patient
Caption: data and they build it over them it gets
Caption: better and better
Caption: so we're trading our data for free now
Caption: it's not every country can do this some
Caption: countries have laws that prohibit black
Caption: box diagnosed so like Sweden for example
Caption: can't use Heidelberg even though they're
Caption: close by so the system their health care
Caption: system does not allow them to be like
Caption: here take these medications I can't tell
Caption: you why you got a static so I almost
Caption: find myself sort of teetering here
Caption: between a Bennett developer for the last
Caption: 20 years I've also been in oncology for
Caption: the last eight there's always a little
Caption: sliver here I can sort of help you know
Caption: also an Xbox players a little bit
Caption: and I think like many of you in here who
Caption: are technologists who are developers
Caption: engineers you look at problems
Caption: differently right you kind of look at
Caption: them and we're like how can you solve it
Caption: and so I'm a colleague of mine dr.
Caption: Melvin chin and sit beside me picture
Caption: here thinking please don't put me in
Caption: your powerpoint he calls me a solution
Caption: Asst he says that I go when I solve
Caption: problems just for the sake of solving it
Caption: even when the problems not that bad but
Caption: a solution takes so much longer than the
Caption: problem positives begin with and he's
Caption: not entirely wrong but sometimes in my
Caption: past I have hit some healthcare problem
Caption: solve all the technology and they
Caption: believe those project behind for the
Caption: solution other people consult
Caption: so obviously this time around I'm like
Caption: all right I've gotta be attacked love is
Caption: something that you do to solve this
Caption: problem and it wasn't a long time it was
Caption: a group in Sweden who I brought up that
Caption: they had the issue that they're not
Caption: allowed to you thought over here in
Caption: Perth I'm concerned to the time but
Caption: group led the hell enough Crellin who
Caption: has a brain tumor group in Gothenburg
Caption: Sweden and one of her postdocs Ahamed
Caption: we've set up front fault and it had to
Caption: accomplish three paths the first had to
Caption: be cheap
Caption: it had to be cheaper than sending your
Caption: samples of hydaburg it had to be
Caption: affordable enough that a hospital budget
Caption: wasn't going to break but implement ease
Caption: it had to be easy
Caption: pathologists aren't going to have the
Caption: ability to take on bioinformatics skills
Caption: they're not going to have the budgets of
Caption: pathology department to hire additional
Caption: expertise and lastly had to be accurate
Caption: we knew going in there was no way we're
Caption: going to develop something as robust as
Caption: the Heidelberg algorithm we knew we
Caption: weren't gonna Ford to spend up to
Caption: hundred cords and run neural networks on
Caption: training set not here half but at the
Caption: output the result was just as accurate
Caption: or better than it doesn't matter so
Caption: first we started by collecting samples
Caption: from the gene expression omnibus just
Caption: this online repository of all the
Caption: genetic information
Caption: there's RNA arrays DNA analysis snip
Caption: that up and also DNA methylation data so
Caption: Mohammed went through it all clean it up
Caption: costing between values at the end of the
Caption: day was able to find 472 PDF
Caption: bring to the samples and database of
Caption: that nine of those different nine for to
Caption: a sofa then using basic kind of linear
Caption: regression modeling ROC curves we cut
Caption: down those 450k arrays as 450,000 bro of
Caption: Rome to a nine hundred probe pool that
Caption: we were able to end to make finger
Caption: prints out of and that became our
Caption: training data set those four hundred
Caption: seventy two two hundred nine hundred pro
Caption: tool again what we use and we've decided
Caption: to make a multi class random forests of
Caption: it and so this part I'm going to get a
Caption: little bit more than details just so if
Caption: anyone's interested especially alert and
Caption: new to modeling maybe can take something
Caption: out of this so the training set fees are
Caption: not going to approach and from that we
Caption: break out into classifiers that n number
Caption: of hot parts each tumor subtype has
Caption: multiple clock parts not this one then
Caption: you take the DNA methylation data from
Caption: your unknown tunic mutation you run this
Caption: through all the pot part it's going to
Caption: match to each one who are very consented
Caption: if it is really a pining of us Belmont
Caption: it's only going to match to a many
Caption: little fingerprint by like making but it
Caption: matches really tight with a piney with
Caption: ninety-three that's a better match then
Caption: you add all those pots powers up the end
Caption: and you get a prediction with a certain
Caption: percent confidence into ball of what to
Caption: Murray
Caption: now this whole thing is done to random
Caption: forests that you're not nor an enormous
Caption: some of you might be some of you might
Caption: not be it's a way of removing
Caption: instability from regression trees so if
Caption: anyone's ever played with any kind of
Caption: regression trees it's done just see them
Caption: in general flowchart that first branch
Caption: rate that first one we decide which way
Caption: to go can be critical because all these
Caption: downstream branches so that first
Caption: division can change how everything ends
Caption: up and that first division is really
Caption: sensitive to your training set your data
Caption: is a little different when you start
Caption: that first division GUI different you
Caption: may get a different answer
Caption: so what a rainforest is it takes you
Caption: gotta set your training set randomly
Caption: deletes one third of it generates a tree
Caption: delete it Brantly delete another 130
Caption: tree another third tree tree tree until
Caption: you have a whole mystery 0 horse and as
Caption: our end apart and so we've run this
Caption: tumor data through the forest then add
Caption: up all that at the end and never move
Caption: that instability that's inherent for
Caption: aggressors we call this whole system
Caption: meth pet
Caption: methylation the other go that's a little
Caption: packets a nice little setup kind of way
Caption: and this solves that first one cost this
Caption: is a very cheap other than the run once
Caption: the hard work is done you can run it on
Caption: your work computer MacBook Pro ace there
Caption: it doesn't matter you don't need a lot
Caption: of cores it's cheap but not very easy to
Caption: use so the last year on my weekends and
Caption: some spare time because I'm actually do
Caption: lung cancer work normally when a job was
Caption: just aside puffle as it were
Caption: I've been working to try to make this
Caption: more easier for pathologist to use or I
Caption: start with methylation data you get
Caption: right from the machine the DNA in the
Caption: collection race normally you put this
Caption: into genome studio this is what we did
Caption: for the first training set data but this
Caption: is a funky piece of software people hate
Caption: it even by our petitions get in
Caption: normalize the data get out do it in Part
Caption: F do it in our get out of this things
Caption: back again pathologist we're not going
Caption: to want to open this up and because we
Caption: different software packages luckily the
Caption: solution to this was solved many years
Caption: ago by Hansen 2011 he reverse engineered
Caption: the Illumina normalization set it's a
Caption: built his logarithm into our software
Caption: and then I pre bundled all the manifest
Caption: data that health healthy array what's on
Caption: the chip world the probes are this is
Caption: something we just did because they
Caption: didn't want the software to have to
Caption: connect the Internet we didn't want some
Caption: pathology department talked computers
Caption: and hospitals can't just connect through
Caption: an open API there's a lot of ports that
Caption: are blocked a lot of patient data that
Caption: sensitive so we bundled all those
Caption: manifests in then we use an open package
Caption: called
Caption: minify we just open up bioconductor it's
Caption: a bunch of tools that allow you to
Caption: manipulate DNA methylation data really
Caption: easily and I use that they calculate
Caption: these intensity differences value and
Caption: then because we're all kind of like
Caption: dirty hackers I just toss that junk into
Caption: like a matrix and then shove that matrix
Caption: in the bath bed and then this whole
Caption: process this pipeline
Caption: I call this methyl DX then I'm not
Caption: committed to the name yet if you guys
Caption: have better ideas come bug me at lunch
Caption: maybe something with a pun and it would
Caption: be really good I like puns this would be
Caption: run on any computer it's really simple
Caption: drag the intensity data file from the
Caption: array on to this and it spits out a
Caption: diagnosis to the conference so now we
Caption: have the first tip we have it's cheap
Caption: now it's easy to use but is it accurate
Caption: give me the wrong diagnosis it's pretty
Caption: much Jesus and so this comes from our
Caption: validation step and this might be one
Caption: cool thing you guys can take away from
Caption: this talk you're not familiar with the
Caption: tripod statement or you're doing any
Caption: kind of modeling at all rarely recommend
Caption: that you check us out this is being
Caption: really pushed hard by Andrew Dekker if
Caption: you're familiar with his work and
Caption: modeling which one tastes pet projects
Caption: basically their types of validation
Caption: steps one being like the least valid
Caption: type for studies be the most valid I'll
Caption: let you go to the website and resolve
Caption: through this flow chart but basically we
Caption: were only able to do one hours of type
Caption: two and we didn't have access to a lot
Caption: of tumors as I previously mentioned
Caption: Franklin redirection is quite rare and
Caption: so what Helena was doing with her team
Caption: is Sweden with she's reaching out to all
Caption: his position friends all across Europe
Caption: trying to get more to the edge of
Caption: regularization and so she was doing that
Caption: for last year while I was doing the
Caption: methyl DX the last year I came over but
Caption: then I accidentally stumbled on the
Caption: summer so my former boss the telephone
Caption: kids who's now at Perth Children's
Caption: Hospital who take for Tahoe over his
Caption: career he's had you know fifteen or
Caption: sixteen brain to be 12 of those
Caption: he sent samples of Heidelberg they were
Caption: not in the original gene omnibus
Caption: training data and he just had that done
Caption: so I was able to take parts isolations
Caption: being so assembler from the rest of the
Caption: world and use that to validate our study
Caption: and jump ahead and conduct a type 4
Caption: validation study now I'm not gonna get
Caption: into some of the crazy maps involved the
Caption: statistics of comparing datasets back
Caption: and forth but I'll just talk to you a
Caption: little quickly about what the results
Caption: kind of were and some interesting issues
Caption: were comparing datasets comparing
Caption: results and maybe we can cover this more
Caption: or less and wants to talk to me
Caption: especially people who have a more
Caption: statistical backgrounds that kind of
Caption: thing but I'd love to hear does so we
Caption: get our 12 tumors and one thing to
Caption: understand is that the official endgame
Caption: diagnosis one thing is written in the
Caption: charts is whatever path West says it is
Caption: they became the goal
Caption: centers for what I was going to care
Caption: about it now path West has access to
Caption: patient histories family history of type
Caption: of cancer they know that has blood tests
Caption: that have CT scans that have the
Caption: biopsies with histology to pathology
Caption: they have access to all the data you can
Caption: imagine make a final decision so the
Caption: doctors do send those samples the
Caption: Heidelberg Heidelberg only gets two
Caption: things one sample the histology and they
Caption: get to run the methylation better they
Caption: don't get all that a scam but path West
Caption: does get Heidelberg report back now
Caption: let's get a little muddy in the water
Caption: half the West makes the final decision
Caption: after reading what other more sensitive
Caption: so you have a great ball but you compare
Caption: Heidelberg is what past West finally
Caption: decided I will burn agreed with half
Caption: west and as 12 times so 83% of the time
Caption: Heidelberg is getting it right in the
Caption: eyes of pathway when you compare that
Caption: mesfet our algorithm it's a little bit
Caption: different it's still kind of interesting
Caption: so for the first tumor for example to
Caption: remember one Heidelberg got it wrong but
Caption: meth-head got it right yay
Caption: unfortunately for tumor number 10 how
Caption: the boy got it right that's had two
Caption: daughters raw who well instinct thing
Caption: that came out of it was this tumor here
Caption: tumor before to River for was a really
Caption: weird-looking tumor it was sort of a
Caption: hybrid of other kinds of tumors and
Caption: looked like a mixture and how to bird
Caption: confidently said I know what that end
Caption: here's one of it path West experts like
Caption: now you're at the ledger crazy meanwhile
Caption: the way I tweaked the confidence
Caption: interval how I said that should agree to
Caption: tell me what something is and how
Caption: confident was for this validation study
Caption: but set to a way where it said I'm look
Caption: at this tumor kind of 36 percent of the
Caption: you know Matt's 36 percent and how
Caption: there's other tumor like twenty eight
Caption: percent but I'm not sure I'm not going
Caption: to tell you what it is because I'm not
Caption: probably enough to make a prediction and
Caption: it said so in that respect I think
Caption: that's a promise a good mark for met pet
Caption: remember Matt pet only has the DNA
Caption: methylation data
Caption: it doesn't have installed these
Caption: predictions are purely unbiased on the
Caption: data set there's no human bias add the
Caption: bevel condemning scope which could be
Caption: pros and cons only maybe stuff then want
Caption: to chat war if you are answer just
Caption: running at a time but like I said if
Caption: anyone wants a chat with me about
Caption: machine learning the algorithms of a
Caption: cancer I love a chat about it this is
Caption: comply me because I can talk about it
Caption: forever when you grab a drink as a
Caption: little party and hang out talk more I do
Caption: want to thank all these supercomputing
Caption: for flying some support for this project
Caption: it's growing government and my actual
Caption: where I work in epicenter first but
Caption: diseases forgive me the time encouraged
Caption: me to pursue the side pocket can
Caption: counselor and then let me come here we
Caption: have a few minutes the questions does
Caption: anyone have any questions the wise
Caption: Allah how the question was how do you
Caption: use the supercomputer at Molesey
Caption: physically but I think what you mean is
Caption: what are we doing with us
Caption: right so the actual validation steps of
Caption: comparing the stat and comparing a lot
Caption: of the values and devaluing our values
Caption: the r-squared and determining use a
Caption: mixed model analysis to figure out how
Caption: good we are predicting models that
Caption: validation map we're doing that on
Caption: magnet we didn't you know probably like
Caption: an an SDN at one point but the tweaking
Caption: that they going back and forth it's not
Caption: like you know varela so when we go back
Caption: from our training set back to our output
Caption: right and you go back your cranks and
Caption: you going to get the right values here
Caption: completing the numbers those the the
Caption: spaces between the bars the SDN became
Caption: so picky that we end up massively
Caption: overfitting and we were like you know
Caption: this is not the approach here for us
Caption: yeah that was sort of we see some
Caption: literature and some other models we kind
Caption: of home-brewed our own sort of scripts
Caption: bring them back and to get in touch with
Caption: folks with value vector we didn't use
Caption: library time for one ball
Caption: it's a great it's a great mix and that's
Caption: something wrong reasons why we kept
Caption: doing it you know it's all volunteer
Caption: work it's a lot of fun
Caption: I forget cause the public fun so a lot
Caption: of the late methylation data
Caption: manipulations done in are all all the
Caption: front-end stuff is done in Java
Caption: one of the most multi platform which is
Caption: easy way for us to do that and both
Caption: familiar with from doing Android apps
Caption: anyway and then we fun with server-side
Caption: stuff entirely but one of the things
Caption: we're trying to do if we can find a host
Caption: I want to put another data of it online
Caption: and then find some of the hook that's
Caption: free just to get people interested and
Caption: pathologist's if you've been playing
Caption: with it because one of the barriers to
Caption: access is getting into all the hospital
Caption: being do the proof run software and we
Caption: can get pathologist to play it that like
Caption: it then they can make a pitch to their
Caption: hospitals that a week thanks again West
Caption: [Applause]